un tableau manipuler avec d'infinies
précautions
il s'agit d'une oeuvre entré dans les
collections du musée en 1875
elle vient d'être entièrement restaurée
et le public peut l'admirer dans un
musée lui aussi rénové
c'était l'occasion en effet ces journées
de patrimoine de montrer montrer ce
musée dans dans sa rénovation dans
certains de ces espaces et puis aussi de
de répondre un petit peu à la thématique
de ceux de ces journées du patrimoine
consacrée à la jeunesse
nous on a intitulé séjourné cure de
jouvence en effet pour entrer justement
dans cette nouvelle ère du musée
plusieurs pièces sont ainsi accessibles
le temps d'un week-end mais attention
pour visiter à nouveau le musée avec les
oeuvres il faudra patienter jusqu'au
printemps prochain
d'octobre à mars nous n'ouvrons pas
encore parce que si le musée a été
effectivement réceptionner les oeuvres
qui ont été touchées par les inondations
sont en cours de restauration
donc elles sont parties dans les
ateliers de restaurateurs notamment
parisiens pour être restaurées et
pouvoir ensuite est à nouveau exposé
dans le musée
il s'agit aussi de construire toute la
muséographie les emplacements mettre les
panneaux indicatifs
voilà c'est tout un ensemble sachant
qu'il faut aussi additionné à cela tous
les dispositifs de médiation que ce soit
une application de visites que ce soit
une programmation pour l'année à venir
voilà de multiples éléments
d'ici là j rodez propose donc un
week-end au musée une petite avant
première à ne pas manquer